E aí
[Música]
o Olá eu sou Mônica milberti e eu tô
muito feliz em participar dessa edição
de seminário Sedex da Universidade de
Coimbra com vocês o poder compartilhar
algumas inquietudes que eu encontrei ao
longo da minha carreira
Olá eu sou nascida no Rio de Janeiro no
Brasil uma cidade realmente maravilhosa
que fica num país não tão Tropical mais
abençoado por Deus e bonito por natureza
eu venho de uma família que tem o mar os
oceanos na verdade como linha mestre que
influencia e direciona de uma maneira
quase imperceptível as nossas vidas e o
nosso destino dele muito cedo eu convivi
vivenciei o mar EA natureza e não podia
ter sido diferente quando eu escolhi
oceanografia como uma carreira pela
indissociabilidade desses ambientes e a
minha própria vida né Eu sou
especialista em ecofisiologia de
mamíferos aquáticos e sim o objeto do
meus estudos se inclui a baleias
golfinhos Lontras Facebook em a i
e claro principalmente finito descrição
uma das minhas maiores paixões é o
integrei iniciativas fantásticas de
estudos de grandes ecossistemas marinhos
eu estudei oceano austral contribuir
para observação dos oceanos estudos de
mudanças climáticas esses assuntos
expandiram meus horizontes e
acompanharam o surgimento evolução e
transformação das minhas inquietudes na
verdade quando a gente pensa em
inquietudes inquietude e geral é o ato
de se preocupar com o que normalmente
está acima do nosso entendimento a minha
trajetória é completa de mudanças
migrações questionamentos sobre opções e
escolhas feitas ao longo da carreira e
na verdade que evoluíram
um novo desafio com cada inquietude que
se apresentava eu espero que esse relato
sirva de contraponto algumas situações
que vocês possam ter vivenciado quando
eu falo de distância com a mente étude
eu vou me ater a três afastamento de Um
porto seguro o primeiro afastamento e a
primeira grande em que tud veio quando
eu sair do Rio de Janeiro e vim para Rio
Grande o sal se analogia esse
deslocamento tinha mais ou menos 1.800
km e foi uma inquietude compartilhada
com a minha família porque representou a
saída de casa viver sozinha ah tá longe
enfrentando o desconhecido o inesperado
e muitas vezes até o indesejado né
a universidade que eu escolhi foi uma
universidade federal pública e gratuita
voltada para o mar eo ecossistema
Costeiro que me proporcionou uma uma
fundamentação teórico-prática uma
formação acadêmica na verdade muito
sólida para fazer as escolhas e seguir a
Carrera que eu tinha escolhido e me
permitiu ter liberdade de pensamento
para escolher os próprios caminhos eu
comecei a minha carreira estudando
mamíferos marinhos encalhados mortos na
praia que precisavam ser recuperados
limpos para poder serem estudados isso
era algo bem diferente do que eu via nos
filmes e documentários e que me empolgou
sobre oceanografia no primeiro momento
mas de uma maneira até meio
Inacreditável eu gostava do trabalho de
campo
o que pouco glamoroso e me dediquei a
ele com a cinco procurando fazer
limonada com os Limões que eu recebi
Apesar de todas as dificuldades eu
concluir essa etapa muito importante na
formação com a minha graduação e essa o
por peça essa inquietude essa vamos ver
se primeiro deslocamento me permitiu a
formação de amizades e parcerias que eu
carrego para o resto da vida e foram
sempre muito importantes e me ajudar a
suplantar a inquietude de que eu
encontrei no caminho principalmente
portar me afastando de um lugar tão
familiar que tinha sido a minha casa no
Rio de Janeiro né o segundo afastamento
que eu vou relatar para vocês foi um
pouquinho
e ele representa mais ou menos oito
1.600 quilômetros que é a distância
entre Rio Grande e raio taxes no Canadá
onde eu fui fazer mestrado e doutorado
estudando lactação e desmame de pipocas
do Porto em cebu Island até as etapa
representou na verdade uma aventura um
desafio interessante a ser vencido
principalmente pelo fato de eu ser
mulher estrangeira sou sul-americana né
e jovem
Tô vendo que desenvolveu um trabalho de
campo Kim na época era Pioneiro e
inovador já o terceiro a deslocamento
que eu vou relatar para vocês ele está
representado pela volta ao Brasil no que
representou uma das experiências mais
ricas que eu já tive que foi a
oportunidade de trabalhar na Antártica
eu fiz parte do primeiro grupo de
estudos de biologia de elefantes
marinhos do programa Antártico
brasileiro um convite que veio por conta
da experiência que eu tinha adquirido
nessas durante essas minhas inquietudes
anteriores né E essa experiência abriu
portas e mostrou que apesar das
distâncias cada vez maiores eu sempre
Encontrei o caminho de volta ao meu
porto seguro cada um desses afastamentos
com incremento
e das distâncias Eles foram suplantados
com as res pelas respectivas inquietudes
dando espaço a novos desafios né o
resultado interessante foram as várias
idas ao continente gelado por períodos
variados de poucos semanas até meses com
diferentes equipes de pesquisadores
durante mais de 20 anos. Uma segunda
inquietude que eu acho importante trazer
para vocês é o trabalho realizado em
ambientes remotos e inóspitos
a atividade de campo quando a gente
trabalha com ecologia de mamíferos
marinhos geralmente nos leva a lugares
isolados inóspitos onde esses organismos
ocorrem naturalmente
e daí a necessidade da gente também se
posicionar o frequentar esses lugares
para poder retratar um animal da maneira
mais não intrusiva possível né essa
atividade até de trabalho em áreas
remotas trouxe uma nova inquietude e
adicionou uma nova dimensão ao que o
chamava de desafio de grande
deslocamento Porque além da distância
também representava afastamento e muitas
vezes isolamento trazendo considerações
importantes sobre segurança e
sobrevivência cebola e a ilha elefante
península Valdés representam a sítios de
campo com uma história de atividades de
pesquisa muito bem sucedidas em função
do planejamento cuidado
a logística adequada e pessoal altamente
qualificado treinado e experiente e
comprometido com o trabalho em equipe
ceboline onde fica a 200 km da Costa da
nova Escócia no Canadá no meio da cena
Atlântico a ilha elefante fica nas
século antes do sul e tanto a cebola
rhaylan quanto a ilha elefante a única
forma de se chegar lá é denasil avião e
particularmente elefante através de
utilização de helicópteros isso por si
só podia representar uma uma inquietude
praticamente intransponível uma barreira
mas com desenvolvimento tecnológico
apoio Logístico e Os Protocolos de
segurança e sobrevivência em locais
o auxiliarão a desmistificação desses
obstáculos Além disso claramente a gente
conta por contamos né com mentores muito
incríveis colegas e ajudantes de Campo
dedicados e mais do que nada o apoio da
família mas Qual o benefício Então se
desse a passar por tudo isso na verdade
estudar esses organismos no seu ambiente
natural é a melhor forma da gente trazer
as respostas e e o conhecimento que é
tão importante para conservação deles na
então a ao mesmo tempo junto com essa
com essa atitude de isolamento vem o
outro aspecto que junta tanto a
distância quanto o isolamento
e diz respeito à a escolhas que a gente
faz né E nesse sentido uma grande
inquietude que eu tive continuar e
permanentemente Durante a minha vida foi
a questão da maternidade na ciência na
minha trajetória particular A
Encruzilhada foi um desvio eu tive a
felicidade de encontrar uma alma gêmea
com quem eu formei uma família e que
contribuiu para mudar toda minha
carreira através de apoio e incentivo em
incondicionalmente como a um verdadeiro
parceiro E além disso as nossas famílias
também a constatação de que a gente pode
ter família Extra sangue famílias que a
gente constrói ao longo da vida
compostas por amigos colegas
de que forma uma uma rede de suporte e
sustentação é muito importante e fez
toda a diferença para transformar o
desafio da maternidade na ciência numa
conquista e ajudando a superar essa
inquietude o apoio dentro e fora da vida
acadêmica através de compartilhamento de
experiências realização de trabalho
voluntário vivência em grupo foram
fundamentais para amenizar muitas das
inquietudes que eu tive quanto à
distância dificuldades e opções não foi
à toa que eu fui estudar no começo da
minha carreira lactação e desmame de
focas do porto no Canadá e depois voltei
a América do Sul para estudar
elefantes-marinhos
em prática o mais importante nessa
narrativa de atitudes foi a constatação
de que com o tempo EA experiência os
desafios são superados ainda que novas
inquietudes surjam nessa trajetória
diante das em dia tu diz afastamento a
resposta que eu encontrei foi confiança
quando a gente fala em usa lamento a
resposta foi coragem e quando eu falo em
escolhas a resposta que veio foi
cumplicidade entretanto em todas elas
apoio foi uma constante fundamental
e nos dias de hoje como mulher mãe
Educadora depois de tudo que eu vivi e
curta e conhecimento que eu adquiri a
minha maior inquietude e preocupação diz
respeito ao legado que eu vou deixar
para novas gerações para meus filhos e
netos a pandemia e o aquecimento global
tem me dado que pensar eles são exemplos
com a mesma problemática ele é atingir
eles atingem o planeta como um todo daí
eu me pergunto como é que eu posso
contribuir com as experiências que eu
tive que que eu posso fazer
e É preciso conhecer saber é preciso se
importar e agir Porque além do clima
existem outros fatores que as que afetam
o planeta e os oceanos todos eles
provocados pela humanidade o meu papel
segue sendo o de ensinar mas também
envolve servir de exemplo o Mário
planeta tem sido fonte de inquietude
pelas mudanças e ameaças que vêm
sofrendo a maioria delas causadas por
nós para suplantar essa inquietude atual
é necessário que haja uma mudança de
comportamento essa mudança de
comportamento esbarrar num aspecto
egoísta meio a de Alto benefício onde a
verdade do indivíduo se sobrepõe a
verdade coletiva MA
Oi para todos na Então isso é o Isso é
uma fonte de preocupação a gente tem que
entender que existem diferenças de
perspectiva e realidade em quase todos
os problemas e elas precisam ser
conciliadas e Integradas para que a
gente encontre soluções eficazes quando
a gente fala especificamente para o
oceano a gente vê que ele é importante
de maneira diferente para grupos
distintos né então alguns o oceano é
visto como uma de uma forma mais lúdica
e nesse grupo eu digo velejadores
esportistas turistas e apreciadores da
natureza tem uma preocupação genuína Mas
um pouco afastada enquanto que existem
aquelas pessoas que são diretamente
afetadas pelo sim
é de uma forma mais visceral como no
caso de pescadores residentes de ilhas e
cidades costeiras comunidades
tradicionais que nesse que dependem do
Mar dos oceanos e dos biomas Associados
para a sobrevivência Então esse é muito
importante a mudança de comportamento
capaz de promover desenvolvimento
sustentável que é o que a gente precisa
requer olhar para os dois lados e
procurar cada um fazer a sua parte
cedendo um pouco em prol do coletivo
Isso é uma lição que a gente precisa
propagar o futuro na verdade não é o
lugar um momento ao qual a gente está se
dirigindo é algo que a gente constrói e
cria no dia a dia a gente precisa
garantir que o desenvolvimento
sustentável ocorra
é através de educação
e fornecendo conhecimento empatia quando
a gente respeita as diferenças e
Equidade quando a gente dá chances
iguais para todos isso se nós estamos
realmente comprometidos o mundo melhor
muito obrigada e até uma próxima
oportunidade
[Aplausos]